I regret being a [ __ ] I regret being a
[ __ ] was the title of the essay and I
must say
the title of the essay broke my heart a
little bit
um you know I just uh it's terrible to
discover that you have been lied to
about this topic
and that it has affected the way
you've lived your life and led to regret
and
um let me say that you
um
you play a very special role in the
universe and
it stems from an absolutely preter
natural commitment to Candor and
openness which I really applaud
and so I think lots of people lots of
women in particular have discovered
the same thing that you found and mostly
the instinct is to move on and not focus
on it right and just quietly Harbor the
the pain and that wasn't your instinct
Your Instinct was to explore it publicly
which I think is great you're doing a
service for young women who are trying
to understand what to think in a world
where they are being told
fictions both by people who know that
they're wrong and people who have misled
themselves
and uh industries that are interested in
portraying the world in some way other
than it is but in any case your essay
struck me because I've heard private
conversations that tread in this topic
I've seen very few public explorations
of it and I thought I thought it was
courageous and and admirable
thank you it's uh you know it's a piece
I've been trying to write honestly since
2017. a lot of people really thought
they were like oh yeah marriage and kids
will do this to you I'm like I was
feeling this way before I was in a
relationship or even had kids and in
fact I actually think the weird in a in
a sad yet understandable way when I read
the draft that I wrote originally I was
talking about how I was looking for a
good relationship and I was realizing
that I might want kids and that is a
much sadder version than I'm in a
healthy relationship and I have a child
it almost makes it a little bit more
um palatable but than being able to for
for the reader themselves there isn't so
much
um there is a little bit of a happy
ending to my story I don't know that
that's the case for everyone which is
sad and hopefully someone will read this
and and and they can maybe
allow me to be their cautionary Tale But
that I think that piece would have been
a lot harder to read in the original
version that I had written back in 2017
when I was really facing a lot of this
stuff mind you I was about three or four
years sober and that is partially what
led to even being able to uncover and
discover a lot of the the feelings that
I had I just wasn't numbing out anymore
the essay really gets to the heart of
the matter and it's very
um
understandable
comprehensible doesn't surprise me that
it took you a while struggling with the
topic to get to such a clear
presentation I think the world has also
I know because I've been trying to raise
this question for many years and I know
what comes back when you do
the world is now changing it is waking
up to the fact that it has made errors
about sex and sexuality
and that it isn't as simple as you know
basically
if we demystify sex and treat it as just
another kind of interaction that things
get better and people are more satisfied
that turns out to be nonsense and it
isn't as simple as people who uh
disagree with that perspective are
somehow prudes right and so anyway what
is the question you ask when you say
you've been asking trying to ask this
question what's the question you ask and
what's the answer that you normally
receive
foreign
has been that sex is
fantastic but it is a precious commodity
and that if what you do is you make it
commonplace
in all of the ways that you might do
that that you rob it of its power
and then I guess my second point is that
the thing that it does in human beings
is so unique that to unhook that power
is incredibly dangerous not just to
relationship building
but also to the way civilization works
and the problem is that sounds I think
so far like a
traditional position right like like
Trad
my position isn't traditional well I
think too just even the one of the or
and I say this in the essay one of the
early things that I bucked against about
sex was that it was presented to me as
if it was a commodity and so already
there's this in inter you know there's
some kind of
um
like the interaction always seems like
it's you're bargaining or bartering or
it gives this idea of like my daughter
who has this you know her virginity and
we have to keep this commodity as as
precious as we possibly can and I think
and being raised Catholic there's a lot
of guilt and weirdness around sex as
well even though they have a million
kids which is kind of funny but there
was this sense of
um guilt around having sex outside of
marriage and whatnot so I feel like
um that was one of the early things I
kind of ins push back against or felt
um felt like I was reacting to and
yeah I don't I don't know maybe maybe it
is just a commodity and like that's the
way it is but I I think it it gives this
it gave me the sense that it was always
transactional like the whole the whole
dealing around my sexuality or my sex
became a transaction and I think part of
me initially becoming somewhat
promiscuous aside from reacting to being
um sexually assaulted
it was also just reacting to a culture
where I felt like it was this sex was a
transaction and women had to like
protect their commodity
um or they were worthless so it became
something that was attached to my value
in a way that I don't think was great
and I know people who were raised with
like healthy messages about sex where
they did not feel that way about sex and
they didn't have that so
um yeah I think unpacking that is is has
been challenging for me as well well
there's a there's a lot in there
and I would say one thing you know
Heather and I explore this a little bit
in our book and we certainly talk about
it on Dark Horse and uh you know off
camera
but
the fact is the asymmetry between humans
the sexual asymmetry is utterly profound
and it is somewhat broken down by modern
realities
right the ability to control when you
produce offspring
has reduced the asymmetry a little bit
and you know paternity tests have
reduced the asymmetry uh in the other
direction right men used to be
have every reason to be concerned about
the possibility of being lied to about
whether an offspring was really theirs
that that's reduced by paternity testing
um women's ability to control when they
produce Offspring means that uh having
sex doesn't inherently carry the kinds
of incredibly high stakes that it once
did yeah but
that said none of the underlying wiring
was changed by these technological facts
and so
the biggest problem with having this
discussion is that that wiring isn't
obvious and the idea that effectively
the distinction in the expectations for
men and women are the result of the
powerful people men oppressing women and
that we can therefore measure whether
women have attained equality or what
fraction of equality they might have
attained by how much of that asymmetry
has evaporated and the problem is no
that asymmetry was biological to begin
with it is written in deeply and the
expectation that it will evaporate when
we are equal is nonsense and so
um we're sort of caught in this
bind where to the extent that there are
still asymmetries evident in the
expectations of females people are like
oh yes that's because we're not we
haven't achieved the goal we're still
not equal I was like
nope that's just not feminism hasn't
been tried
well said yes exactly
um yeah that's that's something too that
it's really fascinating one of the
things that I reacted to was the
asymmetry that men can sleep with
whoever they want and they generally get
applauded as many people women do and
they're considered a [ __ ] I don't think
getting naked and you know having sex
with a lot of men has changed any of
that and perhaps when I evaluate home
and talk to my daughter about this
and as my therapist always said this to
me she's like I just raised my kids to
be like that's just the way it is and I
don't know that I've come to any more of
a conclusion other than which might be
disheartening yes it's a double standard
yes it sucks but that ultimately the
only place I've landed at this moment
that we're talking this might evolve is
like yeah that's just the way it is
that's unfortunately the way it is and I
don't I don't really know I'd like your
thoughts on that yeah well I think the
the truth is both more horrible and a
lot better than okay that suggests here
here's the you know
let's just be honest about this the game
theory surrounding
the distinction between the Sexes is
pretty well understood in the realm of
ethology and ethnology that is the study
of animal behavior and the study of
human cultures
this isn't that complex it's incredibly
strange and counter-intuitive which is
why it's not well known in public but
why the asymmetry is there is pretty
obvious and how it can play out is
mostly obvious too if you know kind of
where to stand
but here's one of the things that people
I think don't don't really grasp
this system in which sex is uh
commonplace and commodified
um
isn't good for men either now there's
one caveat I have to give you which is
that for very powerful men right like
really wealthy men
it's arguably evolutionarily positive
doesn't mean they're happy but it does
mean that for those at the very top of
the male mating hierarchy there's an
argument that this system is functional
for almost everybody else
it's bad
[Music]